en el vídeo pasado estuvimos platicando
acerca de qué sucede cuando una empresa
se va a la bancarrota y se tiene que
liquidar todo es decir estábamos en una
situación en la cual una empresa estaba
muy endeudada pero además ya no tenía
sentido que continuara con su negocio
con sus operaciones porque pues ya el
mercado era distinto o porque sus
máquinas ya estaban muy descompuestas o
lo que fuera entonces lo que teníamos
que hacer era vender todo el activo y
empezar a pagar primero las deudas y
después si sobraba dinero y pagarle algo
a los accionistas bueno qué sucedería si
tenemos ahora una empresa que también
está en una situación en la cual estaba
muy endeudada pero sigue siendo muy
buena generando efectivo tiene sentido
que esta empresa se vaya a una
bancarrota por liquidación pues no en
realidad no tiene sentido porque todavía
con un poco de ayuda podría pagar sus
deudas entonces lo que quiero hacer en
este vídeo es platicar de un segundo
tipo de bancarrota que es la bancarrota
por reestructuración déjame escribir los
dos tipos acá arriba
liquidación 1 era la bancarrota por
liquidación y esta que vamos a ver
ahorita es la bancarrota por
reestructuración reestructuración en
eeuu se conocen respectivamente como la
bancarrota del capítulo 7 y como la
bancarrota del capítulo 11 esto es
importante por si alguna vez veces las
noticias así en eeuu y ves que una
empresa se va digamos a bancarrota de
capítulo 11 van bueno entonces
supongamos que vamos a hacer un poco más
concretos que tenemos una empresa
digamos de automóviles y de automóviles
porque se puso un poco de modesto de las
bancarrotas de las empresas de
automóviles que tenemos una empresa de
automóviles que acá tiene su activo
activo y como activo tiene una fábrica
una fábrica de coches y además tiene un
terreno muy grande un terreno y tiene
muchas tiendas de coches
entonces tenemos una fábrica de coches
algo de este estilo
supongamos que por acá también tenemos
deuda deuda y que por acá abajo tenemos
capital capital
entonces pues usualmente que sucede
bueno qué pasa con el activo de una
empresa pues está activo si las cosas
van bien empieza a generar efectivo
dejando ponerle por acá que genera
efectivo
efectivo y con este efectivo bueno se
pueden hacer otras inversiones pero
principalmente este efectivo se utiliza
para pagar parte de los intereses de la
deuda intereses y después ese después de
pagar estos intereses se pasa aquí abajo
como dividendos para los accionistas
dividendos ahorita no me voy a meter
mucho en los detalles después cuando
veamos el estado de resultados vamos a
ver un poco más claro esto de acá pero
bueno este efectivo parte de lo que se
tiene que hacer con este efectivo es
pagar intereses por una deuda que
pedimos va por un préstamo que pedimos
pero qué sucede si un año esta empresa
de coches por alguna razón no puede
pagar digamos que en el semestre le fue
mal y no pudo obtener tanto efectivo o
que se metió en una deuda de tasa
variable y la tasa de repente se fue por
los cielos entonces qué pasa en este
caso
qué hacemos
qué hacemos pues vamos a ver qué pasa ya
tendría sentido vender este activo de
acá para pagar la deuda
o sea si tenemos todo este activo pues
ve la fábrica puede que esté muy lejos
el terreno también puede que esté muy
lejos y además está baldío y a lo mejor
muy desgastado ya no sirve para otro
tipo de uso y las tiendas pues son
tiendas especialmente diseñadas para
vender coches entonces en realidad esto
se va a vender en muy poquito dinero y
es mucho más útil tiene mucho más
sentido que se siga utilizando este
activo para generar efectivo y
eventualmente poder pagar la deuda sin
embargo el banco al que no le pagamos el
interés va a estar enojado y si nos va a
querer llevar a algún tipo de bancarrota
y el tipo de bancarrota que nos va a
llevar es a uno de reestructuración todo
el mundo está de acuerdo que no conviene
liquidarnos entonces vamos a entrar en
una bancarrota de reestructuración
vamos a ver qué pasa así paso a paso
cuando nos llevan a una bancarrota de
reestructuración bueno primero lo
primero es que la corte toma posesión de
todos los activos la corte de bancarrota
dice bueno ahorita el activo es mío y te
voy a hacer un préstamo te voy a hacer
un préstamo que se llama un préstamo de
deudor en posición entonces la corte de
bancarrota aquí agrega un pasivo a
nuestra empresa pero eso tiene un activo
correspondiente verdad que es efectivo
déjame ponerle por acá que nos llegará
más efectivo
pero acá tenemos un préstamo préstamo de
deudor en posesión deudor en posesión
también lo puedes ver como depp por las
siglas en inglés este préstamo es un
préstamo de altísima prioridad de
altísima jerarquía de hecho tiene más
jerarquía que cualquiera de estos
préstamos de acá incluso que los de los
de garantías preferenciales y pues de
cualquier otro que platicamos en el
vídeo pasa cubano entonces éste es un
préstamo así super grande con éste se
pueden pagar las deudas con esto la
empresa puede seguir éste con su negocio
con sus operaciones pagarle a sus
distribuidores y lo que sea pero luego
empieza un lío legal así enorme todas
estas partes de acá
estas dos bueno de todos estos
prestamistas y los inversionistas los
dueños de las acciones contratan
abogados déjame ponerle por acá que
contratan abogados y esos abogados
empiezan a negociar puede ser que
diferentes de diferentes prestamistas
contraten diferentes abogados estos
abogados empiezan a negociar contratan a
un banco
puede ser que cada uno contrate a un
banco distinto y van a empezar a
intentar hacer algún tipo de acuerdos
para entonces entre los abogados el
banco y las partes lo primero que van a
intentar hacer es pues ver cuánto vale
esta empresa de acá para que para poder
hacer un plan de bancarrota en realidad
los planes de bancarrota son de
distintas naturalezas pero básicamente
se reducen a lo siguiente estos de acá
lo primero que hacen es ver en cuánto
está valuada esta empresa va a dejar de
poner numeritos
en numeritos de lo que valía antes
supongamos que esta empresa antes antes
de este préstamo de acá arriba su activo
valía 10 millones que aquí en deuda
tenía 6 millones y en capital tenía 4
millones esta es la empresa antes de la
bancarrota entonces este banco digamos
el de acá arriba digamos el banco de
estos de acá va a proponer un plan un
plan de bancarrota y más o menos el plan
consiste en lo siguiente lo primero es
evaluar cuánto todavía vale la empresa o
sea cuánto pues realmente puede seguir
generando que también está la compara
con otras empresas de la misma rama de
la misma industria y después de hacer un
montón de análisis el banco dice sabes
que yo creo que esta empresa a su lado
izquierdo que es su activo nada más vale
5 millones entonces este bonito va a ser
una propuesta
y así una propuesta de bancarrota
en la cual el activo ahora vale 5
millones y por supuesto como el activo
ya nada más vale 5 millones pues está
imposible poder pagar 6 millones en
deuda o sea toda todo tu activo es sólo
de 5 millones y tu efectivo que generas
va a ser menos entonces va a tardar
muchísimo así que no sólo hay una
propuesta de cuánto vale el activo sino
también hay una propuesta de cuánto se
puede pagar entonces por ejemplo
por ejemplo
y el monito propone que todavía se
pueden pagar 3 millones de deuda bueno
qué sucede aquí abajo esto de aquí lo
que sobra se convierte en el nuevo
capital
voy a ponerle aquí nuevo nuevo capital
ahorita vamos a platicar un poco de
cuáles son las prioridades de cada quien
pero la idea es que a estos monitos a
los prestamistas les conviene que sus
bancos valoren la empresa en muy poquito
y a los inversionistas les conviene que
su empresa si está evaluada en algo muy
alto pero como se le asigna la deuda que
va a pasar ahora con la deuda y con el
capital y a quién le toca que pues ve
aquí arriba tenemos algunos prestamistas
de alta prioridad te acuerdas de alta
jerarquía estaban los que estaban
garantizados y tenían preferencia los
que estaban garantizados pero no tenían
preferencia y así entonces tenían
distintas jerarquías déjame indicar por
acá algunos de ellos ya estoy acá el a
el b y el c entonces de arriba para
abajo se les va asignar primero a este a
este ya este deuda entonces este de acá
tenía por decir algo este un millón
3 millones y el acá tenía 2 millones de
deuda entonces se les va a asignar de
arriba para abajo deuda entonces ahora
aquí tenemos un millón de a luego
tenemos 3 millones de b/d voy a poner
aquí un cachito
3.000.000 ahorita te explico esta parte
de acá y aquí tenemos lo que sobra que
es un millón entonces qué pasa con estos
debe pues los debe reciben deuda de la
nueva empresa de la nueva hoja de
balance pero además entran un poquito en
el capital entonces parte de su deuda ya
no va a ser deuda sino que ahora van a
ser dueños de la empresa y puedes ver
que cuando una empresa se se va a ir a
una bancarrota de reestructuración hay
muchas personas que empiezan a comprar
bonos por qué justo pueden caer en esta
situación pueden caer en la situación de
que sus bonos se conviertan en acciones
de la nueva empresa bueno déjame seguir
por aquí abajo luego teníamos los de cee
los de se eran otro tipo de prestamistas
de menor prioridad y a esos nada más les
van a tocar acciones y no acciones
correspondientes a su préstamo que era
de 2 millones si no nada más de un
millón más entonces pues ellos si
perdieron algo de dinero y bueno bueno
tienen tienen pues más o menos una razón
por eso porque estuvieron cobrando más
intereses
está bien ahora así quedaría asignada la
deuda y el capital el capital antiguo ya
no vale nada es decir otra vez a los
accionistas no les toca nada
ahora estamos en esta situación de acá
que sucede sea la empresa le empieza a
ir muy bien qué sucede si la empresa se
recupera solo tuvo aquí arriba un año
muy difícil o un semestre muy difícil y
qué pasa en esta situación pues entonces
la empresa va a empezar a volver a
producir a su buen ritmo el activo va a
volver a valer lo que valía no va a leer
10 millones
10 millones la deuda no crece si la
empresa le va bien bueno a menos que
haga más préstamos pero que pida más
préstamos pero supongamos que no esto
sigue siendo de 3 millones y acá abajo
el capital ahora se convierte en 7
millones 7 millones entonces observa
estos cuates de acá que son los de se
obtuvieron buenos ya tenía una deuda de
2 millones prestaron dos millones
entonces luego se convirtió en un millón
en acciones pero es un millón en
acciones ahora creció muchísimo verdad
ya lograron hacer soja costo les fue
súper bien y por esta razón muchas
personas empiezan a comprar bonos cuando
una empresa va a caer en bancarrota van
ok entonces esta es una posible
situación en la cual le va mal a estos
de acá a los que son los accionistas
antiguos porque ahora no obtuvieron nada
así que ellos por su parte ellos por su
parte quieren hacer una propuesta en la
cual les vaya un poco mejor entonces
digamos estos del capital lo que quieren
es que la hoja de balance más bien se
vea algo de este estilo
quieren decir no sabes que me activo no
es tan malo de hecho estoy produciendo
muy bien entonces me activo ok no vale
10 millones pero si vale unos buenos 8
millones 8 millones y además para que
veas que no que no estoy así
inventándome cosas si puedo pagar mucha
deuda no solo puedo pagar 3 millones
como dicen estos sino que puedan pagar a
4 millones
4 millones entonces a ellos les conviene
que su activo valga mucho y que su
pasivo valga valga poco o sea que
parezca que pueden pagar menos porque
entonces su capital aumenta verdad
entonces ahora tendríamos capital de
esta forma
y cómo se reorganiza todo pues bueno
teníamos 6 millones de deuda en total
que se va a repartir por acá entonces
estos 6 millones de deuda ahora aquí
está el un millón de a voy a poner con
otro color con color naranja y aquí está
un millón de a luego están los tres
millones debe los tres millones debe
creo que están los dos millones desea
y finalmente queda un cachito aquí abajo
lo voy a poner con azul de 2.000.000 que
es para los antiguos accionistas los
antiguos accionistas
listas
entonces esta situación les conviene más
a los accionistas anteriores a los de
antes de la bancarrota porque ahora sí
al menos fue su capital baja verdad baja
de 4 millones a 2 millones pero al menos
pues no se quedan así con las manos
vacías bueno entonces estoy acá es más o
menos la idea de la bancarrota por
reestructuración y otra vez es que las
operaciones continúen y esto confunde
mucho a algunas personas porque a veces
escuchan que una empresa se va a la
bancarrota y no se pueden explicar por
qué la empresa sigue funcionando y más
aún no se pueden explicar cómo la
empresa se puede volver a ir a la
bancarrota pues es justo porque hacen
bancarrota de reestructuración de hecho
ahí hay un chiste muy simpático que
cuando una empresa se va a bancarrota
por estructuración una vez y luego otra
y luego otra se dice que entra primero
al capítulo 11 y luego al 22 y luego al
está bueno entonces
bueno en textos de eso se trata la
bancarrota de reestructuración la
empresa sigue operando el activo sigue
funcionando en realidad los empleados
siguen yendo a la fábrica a los
vendedores siguen vendiendo a ellos les
va igual se les sigue pagando porque
tenemos un préstamo para poder continuar
con las operaciones a los prestamistas
de alta prioridad pues también les va
bien porque de todas formas siguen
teniendo su deuda bueno siguen teniendo
este pues está activo este activo que es
una deuda de esta empresa y a los que
les puede ir un poco mal y pues
realmente depende un poco de cómo
progresa la empresa después es a esto se
acaban los prestamistas bajos y claro a
los inversionistas antiguos ok entonces
cuando cuando por decir algo general
motors se fue a bancarrota o imaginando
que general motors se fuera a bancarrota
si general motors se va a bancarrota
entonces sus acciones actuales actual
se irían a cero ya no valdría nada y
ahora habría nuevos nuevos
inversionistas nuevos accionistas que
tendrían acciones de general motors
nuevas nuevas bandas entonces esta es la
mecánica de una bancarrota por
reestructuración la empresa sigue
funcionando a los empleados se les sigue
pagando y bueno espero que te haya
gustado este vídeo nos vemos hasta la
próxima